ten thousand sharks from two endangered
species that's how many were killed to
fill this room with 29 tons of shark
fins destined for Asia
authorities in Brazil seized the
shipment from an export company in the
southern Santa Catarina State while
confiscating more at the airport in Sao
Paulo
one of the usual practices in the world
is known as Finning in which the shock
is captured and has as fin sliced off
which are the desired pots and then the
rest of the animals dumped into the sea
the animal lives in suffering in agony
so in addition to wasting the animal you
end up causing suffering
shark fin is a traditional delicacy in
parts of Asia often consumed in soup
it's considered a symbol of prosperity
and good fortune it's estimated 100
million sharks are killed each year 70
percent solely for their fins
scientists say it's pushed most shark
species to the brink of Extinction
threatening the world's Marine ecosystem
if you fail to bend this kind of thread
will be increased more demand and also
we will lose our shock conserventions
effort that actually many organizations
including green peas will wanna really
see this kind of shark consequence to be
effective not only on the paper but also
on the field level
last November 183 countries approved a
plan to protect some of the most
trafficked shark species from Finning
with the illegal trade worth half a
billion dollars a year it'll be
difficult to stop this practice
Al Jazeera